Jason Statham is just as committed to
doing his own stunts he's even performed
a choreographed fight scene while
dangling from a helicopter three
thousand feet above Los Angeles for
crank but one stunt for Expendables 3
was so crazy you need to hear this so
Jason was driving a truck along the
docks of the Black Sea in Bulgaria when
the brakes suddenly failed the truck hit
two cameramen before careening into the
sea 60 feet at the bottom of the Black
Sea stuck in the mud thinking hang on a
minute I'm going to get out of this
Jason was weighed down by his boots and
jacket but that didn't stop him the
survival sort of kicks in and you pull
yourself out the window you stop
grabbing at the war he managed to swim
to shore where he was met by Sylvester
Stallone asking Jason you knew the towel